- In areas where deer roam freely,
residents must dress to protect themselves
against deer ticks that
might transmit diseases.
This actually looks pretty good.
In areas, and we're talking
about what type of areas?
Well, these are areas
where deer roam freely.
We're starting with this relative pronoun.
This is the type of areas.
Areas where deer roam freely.
This looks pretty good.
I like it as is, and so I'll
go with the first choice,
which is always the as is.
So no change to the underline.
But let's just go through the other ones,
to make sure that they're not as good
or nowhere near as good.
So in areas roamed by deer freely,
residents must dress to
protect themselves, et cetera.
This one isn't as good, because
this part right over here
is in the passive voice.
Instead of saying deer roam freely,
we're saying roamed by deer freely.
So it sounds a little bit convoluted.
Most writers will tell
you the passive voice
you should avoid it,
unless you really need to,
unless it really does something special
to what you're writing.
And so, I would definitely avoid this
because of that passive voice.
So B I'd rule out.
C has the same problem.
Areas freely roamed by deer.
It's a little bit better.
The adverb freely is
in front of the roamed,
so they're closer together.
So how are they roaming?
They're roaming freely.
But once again, it's in the passive voice.
Freely roamed by deer,
instead of just saying
the deer roam freely.
So I don't like that one as well.
Both of these are in the passive voice,
which in general you should avoid.
Areas in which there are
deer that roam freely.
So the in which part is okay.
You could replace a
where with an in which,
where in this case the which
is the relative pronoun,
and we put a preposition
here to talk about,
well, how do we relate to the area?
Are we doing it on it?
Are we doing it in it?
Where are the deer?
Well, the deer are in it.
They're in which.
So, areas in which deer roam freely.
So you could say in areas
in which deer roam freely.
The problem I have with
this one is this part.
There are deer that roam freely.
There are deer that roam
freely is much longer than
deer roam freely, unnecessarily
long, unnecessarily wordy.
And so, if you can get it across
in a nice clean way, you should.
And so, I would rule this one out,
just because it's wordier
and a little bit more
complex than it needs to
relative to our original clause here.
Areas which deer roam free.
So the problem here is we have
the relative pronoun which,
but we're not saying how do we relate.
How do we relate to those
areas that we're referring to?
In particular, how do
the deer relate to them?
Well, the deer are in them.
You need to put that in which.
This needs an in right over here.
Without the in, this isn't
right really, grammatically.
Areas which deer roam free.
No, the deer are in the area.
So I'd cross that one out as well.